aller retour en france avec la colère et
l'inquiétude des habitants
d'aubervilliers et deux pantins et cela
45 jours après le déplacement des
toxicomanes porte de la villette à paris
ils se sont mobilisés une nouvelle fois
hier soir des riverains et des élus qui
protestent contre l'inaction des
pouvoirs publics
ils réclament l'évacuation et du site et
la prise en charge des usagers sur le
krach en dehors des zones urbaines 28
octobre dernier une jeune femme avait
été retrouvée morte nous abords du
square de la ville est justement on va
en parler avec notre invité qui nous a
rejoint stéphanie benoit elle est
présidente du village 47 chemin
[Musique]
bonjour stéphanie benoit d'un genre
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france nouvelle
mobilisation hier soir contre la
présence de ces toxicomanes et ses
dealers de crack à la porte de la
villette ça fait quarante cinq jours que
kylie à des manifestations régulièrement
où en est on
on est alors bonjour on en est la
situation s'empire de jour en jour
puisque les consommateurs sont de plus
en plus nombreux sur le terrain
donc qui dit nombre de consommateurs
plus important dit évidemment que les
problématiques et les dommages
collatéraux qui surviennent sur les
riverains bas sont aussi plus important
on est d'autant plus soumis à la
mendicité agressive des agressions pour
se procurer en fait le moindre sou afin
de pouvoir assouvir leur besoin de se
droguer et de récupérer leur drogue donc
la situation se tend ce les tensions se
cristallisent de plus en plus et et en
contrepartie à côté de ça sur le terrain
à ses consommateurs vivent vivent dans
des conditions d'insalubrité tel où les
rôles vont même plus
est en fait là on a on voit plus le
l'issue l'issue de tout problème est qu
est ce que vous voyez répondre les
autorités aujourd'hui justement face à
cette situation face à vos alertes
les autorités ne nous répondent pas
c'est assez rapide comme réponse ne nous
répondent pas sa part monsieur
l'allemand qui a été interviewé sur les
jeunes confrères lundi soir lequel
évoque encore une fois le fait que cet
emplacement est un des emplacements
isolé dans paris alors dans une capitale
comme les paris on a du mal à croire
qu'il y ait des emplacements isolé
et la mère de marie aussi parce qu'ils
refusent de prendre en charge les
toxicomanes
alors la maire de paris
on n'a pas non plus nos vies
c'est la même problématique aussi on a
alerté en fait aussi bien le
gouvernement que d'autres élus la région
la région aussi c'est vrai que
malheureusement personne se saisit du
dossier je pense que dans dans un
contexte de campagne présidentielle il
va être quand même important que la tête
des candidats en face un sujet de
campagne parce que l'on cherche aussi
nous a protégé les rires à protéger les
enfants qui sont les exposer à des
scènes de deux shoots en pleine rue on
cherche à les protéger aussi des dealers
parce que faut pas oublier que les
dealers sont présents sur le terrain et
et que leur business
bava fructifier au fur et à mesure où
les consommateurs dans son de menthe et
donc il est quand même important ils
vont y a pas que ce volet sécuritaire il
ya un volet de prise en charge sanitaire
et sociale et médicale qui doit être
assuré pour ces pour ces individus que
je vais rencontrer assez régulièrement
valérie pécresse s'est souvent mobilisés
auprès des habitants du quartier à
l'époque où il était dans le 18e
arrondissement
vous sentez soutenu par par d'autres
politiques
alors on l'a vu madame pécresse
effectivement le dimanche
suite au déplacement le 26 septembre ce
dimanche à elle est venu effectivement
sur le sur le quartier des quatre
chemins
depuis on a vu qu'on a vu à part les
élus locaux donc le maire de pantin
d'aubervilliers monsieur bastien la
chaux aussi qui sont régulièrement qui
assiste régulièrement à nos
manifestations et a d'ailleurs les
remercie
on ne voit personne
de manière temporaire on voit aussi le
maire de dieu de paris 19e monsieur
d'ayew
mais pour le reste
aujourd'hui on n'a plus de nouvelles de
personne en fait donc justement j'invite
toutes ces personnes à ceux à se
mobiliser à puis à prendre conscience
que la l'urgence le stade d'urgence
s'est largement dépassé on va en plus
ces personnes véhicules d'importantes
maladie sur le terrain
donc ça va vraiment ça devient vraiment
et ça l'est déjà depuis un moment un
problème de santé publique stéphanie
benoit on vous parlait enfin beaucoup de
personnes du quartier également part
d'une zone de la mort à présent avec
justement les décès qui s'accumulent on
l'a vu le 28 octobre dernier une jeune
femme retrouvée dans des toilettes morte
c'est un promeneur elle a été retrouvé
dans les toilettes elle a été retrouvée
au pied du seul bâtiment qui existe sur
ce terrain et effectivement
il ya une autre personne qui est décédée
une
jeune femme de la nièvre de 31 ans alors
ça c'est fou parce que quand elle serait
décédée nul oui oui mais pour ce qui est
de celles qui est décédé le 28 octobre
et maui lmbc a été confirmée par
plusieurs sources officielles
elle est cédée donc le 28 octobre
dernier elle avait 28 ans et
on craint que les conditions
d'insalubrité du terrain comme je vous
le disais qu'ils entraînent donc
d'importantes maladie parce que ce sont
des personnes qui sont finalement qui se
font pas soigné qui ne sauveront pas
suivre médicalement et on craint que ce
soit le début d'une longue série on ne
souhaite pas en arriver là parce que
très honnêtement voir des personnes
mourir sous ses fenêtres
c'est c'est abominable comme image et on
ne doit pas de mouz nous rivera nous
exposer à ça on ne doit pas exposer les
enfants les au delà au delà au delà des
riverains il ya quand même des groupes
scolaires aussi aux abords de ce terrain
qu'il faut pas il faut pas il faut pas
minimiser
l'importance de toutes les
problématiques
ces toxicomanes qui vous racontent aussi
leur détresse est ce que vous observez
est ce qu'il ya des ong sur place à ce
que des personnes essayent de les aider
du mieux possible aujourd'hui
alors de ce qu'il en ressort des
échanges qu'on peut avoir avec eux pas
suffisamment il y en a il ya quelques
associations quelques maraude qui se
font les deux principales oro reghaïa
jeu notamment par la variable pour les
pourvoir leur car leur but ce qui est
garée à proximité du terrain ne vont pas
sur le terrain c'est ce qui nous est dit
des consommateurs ils ne vont pas sur le
terrain il se positionne quelques
trentaine cinquantaine de mètres en face
d'un camp de
houlé ligue ans
régulièrement déposés par l'écart de la
bapsa le matin et récupérer le soir donc
ce car ce gars là et
ils demandent en fait aux consommateurs
de venir vers ce quart pour leur fournir
il faut essentiellement les kits eau
stérile d'injection ou les pipes à crack
merci beaucoup stéphanie benoit de nous
avoir livré en direct votre témoignage
ce matin dans la matinale d'arte merci à
vous